das legen wir echt lustig hierdurch zu
laufen und immer nur auf 50 cent zu
achten oder unter 50 jahren da mal kurz
das video volk über und dann vielleicht
online kommt alte beschweren kann man
sich da normalerweise eher weniger oder
[Musik]
mir ist gerade irgendwie aufgefallen
dass ich gar kein anfang vom blog
gemacht habe tut mir leid deswegen muss
man das jetzt machen ich bin schon hier
in berlin angekommen eigentlich sache
des ganzen in köln werde hier auch
gleich sehen ich bin jetzt allerdings
noch mal kurz das fenster zu bild es
schon dunkel draußen ich bin jetzt
allerdings die nächsten drei tage hier
in berlin heute abend ist youtube
premium lounge party youtube hat da
irgendwas neues entwickelt bin ich mal
gespannt und reiter habe ich auch noch
was wichtiges vor vielleicht kommt das
auch noch mit diesem blog ich habe mir
allerdings für dieses video
beziehungsweise für den block mal wieder
eine kleine trends überlegt habe ich in
den kommentaren gelesen zu dem letzten
video von mir wo ich gesagt habe okay
wir versuchen einfach mal 24 stunden
überhaupt kein geld auszugeben falls ihr
das du nicht gesehen habt schaut euch
das auf jeden fall an bis am ende
verlinkt und zwar geht es heute darum
ich neun war schon einkaufen einfach mal
nur mit produkten die unter 50 cent
liegen zu reden wie das ist im
supermarkt ja teurer man kauft ja auch
eigentlich ja alleine schokoriegel
kostet schon 60 70 80 cent und wenn man
mal so nachdenkt ist unglaublich extrem
wenige produkte die man benutzt unter 50
cent es gibt sie aber und ja ich würde
sagen wir springen nach köln heute
morgen viel spaß mit dem video weites
feld das noch mal um da ich schreibe
gerne weitere ideen was man noch machen
kann in die kommentare und ich mache
jetzt noch schnell die lupe von der wohl
und wer ist eigentlich echt schön dass
sie dir dann gleich als die kamera auch
wieder sauber
das ist ziemlich jetzt habe ich noch
zwei brezeln für 50 cent geholt 9 30165
setzt sich damit noch shampoo 54
das wird schwierig glaube ich shampoo
wird um 40 cent hier nicht naja dann
gibt es halt kein shampoo gt über werde
ich wenn ich habe mir auch nicht mit
shampoo die haare gewaschen so leute ich
bin jetzt wieder zurück ist unser recht
verein zugehört wenn ich habe jetzt 43
bezahlt für alles lieben produkte also
hat genau so fasst manchmal muss man
halt fand zahlen dann ging es los mit
dem zug
mal probiert ich weiß zwar wie teuer
am tag des herrn 45 sind eine frische
brise kann man sich beschweren kann man
sich da normalerweise eher weniger oder
aber schwer nicht normalerweise auch
nicht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
tomatenmark 49 sind nämlich leute ich
komme gerade frisch von netto und das
einzige was die hacken war wirklich sehr
wenig habe ein bisschen was aufgenommen
werden wie tomatenmark ja dass ich habe
heute den aufstrich besucht wird das
zeugs hier das gab's schon 49 sind das
auch hier waren im angebot sind die auch
teurer was aber geil war es jetzt schoko
drinks für ich würde auf 940 sind wenn
ich mal gespannt wie das schmeckt ich
habe gar noch zwei freundin in berlin
besucht die sich denken was ich hier
dann mache kann ich auch verstehen
also ich hätte jetzt schlechter erwartet
dann haben wir hier will ich eine knospe
brot
dann waren wir in unserem apartment
jetzt kommt die kultur hier haben wir
ein sofa da ist ein ultimatives genialer
panasonic smardtv flatscreen das hier
ist ein esstisch hier ist die küche die
echt cool aussieht so etwas hätte ich
gern zu hause haben wir leider nicht
auch das sind meine füße hier ist das
bad was geht badewanne waschbecken
waschmaschine was das ist keine ahnung
kann man sich glaubt die füße und sauber
machen das ist unser zimmer mit einem
wirklich sehr gemütlichen bett das ganze
ist wirklich sehr modern hier hier kann
man die klimaanlage make up boom ho
verändert sich jetzt das licht
er ist an hng verstehe ich das jetzt
nicht
ach so ja habe ich nicht verstanden
spiegel
das ist kluge und das war eigentlich
schon also an die dabei kommen
ja das ist der wunderschöne und da ist
ein motorradfahrer
[Musik]
also für uns gezielt auf die youtube hat
hier nämlich die nicht mit aber
vielleicht blende ich euch ein paar
schnäpse
das ist das deutsche wort fürs netz dann
morgen so leute willkommen zurück
lächelt ganz kurz ein bisschen mehr und
zwar wenn ich morgen am 15
auf der video korn in klagenfurt das
ganze findet in österreich statt kommt
auf jeden fall vorbei wird mich mega
freuen video kann
wir können vor dass man umso ich noch
gesagt haben also klagenfurt österreich
bis morgen wir sehen er hat sich
freilich wir haben es schon den nächsten
tag die party war auf jeden fall echt
grün ja erstmal youtube hd und danach
der university also dass ihr sohn
musiklabel das war auch mega cool ich
glaube ich habe hier ist alles voll mit
spiegeln ich glaube ich habe euch ein
paar snacks leben ins video eingeblendet
wir müssen jetzt auf jeden fall die
unterkunft wechseln sind jetzt woanders
zu mächtigen das zimmer sieht ja
eigentlich ganz gut aus er ist ein
bisschen voll mit irgendwelchen
klamotten das gute ist hier direkt
nebenan ist wieder ein alibi und ein
ziemlich günstig da gehen wir jetzt mal
hin und kaufen was zu essen und danach
geht es noch zu aaron youtube video
drehen das ist der plan für heute und
ich würde sagen gar nicht lang la band
let's go ich hab schon marie auch
insgesamt vier euro bekommen ich soll ja
was mitbringen und das natürlich
ausgenommen von meinem 50 cent essen
oder unter 50 sein dass deswegen kann
man so ein teurer sein aber er sich ja
ich versuche auf jeden fall auch mal
wachs zu bekommen für unter 50 cent bei
meiner haare sind echt total auswahl
gestern das auch schon so aus er ist
aldi das legen wir euch müsste hierdurch
zu laufen und immer nur 50 oder unter
punkt sind
ich habe mir das leichter vorgestellt
vieles was auch so 59 sein
man fand berücksichtigen wir jetzt mal
nicht so läuft
er wird mit der tüte fünf euro bezahlt
abzüglich diese chips und jetzt will ich
mal gespannt wie das hier ist übrigens
das hotel wo wir sind ist eigentlich
echt cool
die peri on wax habe jetzt leider nicht
gefunden das hat irgendwie alles
mindestens über ein euro gekostet voll
schade aber sogar wurstaufschnitt für 40
cent
mal sehen erstmals soll es mit dem
kassenzettel ihr mich verarschen leute
schaut euch das mal nicht ob wir können
es lesen ich habe so 10 sachen geholt
und für die tasche hat die mir gesagt
berichtet die 45 centers stand auf und
jetzt steht er einfach 199 wir sind
keine chips wir haben 1 29 euro kostet
wir haben zwei brötchen von zusammen 28
cent auf diesem getränk war anscheinend
doch kein pfand dass er 45 cent gekostet
ja einfach wurstaufschnitt für 49 cent
salzstangen für deutschland für 99 sind
was ja irgendwie auch ohne pfand für 29
cent wenn joghurt 35 cent und diesen
york glaube ich auch mit 35 cent
dieser pilz gummibären waren im angebot
für genau 50 also ich hab jetzt für zehn
sachen ja nicht mal fünf euro bezahlt
eigentlich wie hatte mag habt ihr schon
mal gegessen
[Musik]
ihr problem an dass das ein 50 cent
gekostet mir doch mal ein mal
ich war ein jahr das bessere ist
vergessen aber man kann so ein ding
ich wünsche ich über die runden kommen
ich mache mir jetzt auf dem weg zu
arbeit und das gleich zwei mal kurz das
video volk rüber und donnerstag dann
vielleicht online-kommentar hatte jetzt
nein nix geweckt richtig dass wir
zusammen waren allerdings schon jetzt
schnell weg
so leute wie du völlig gedreht und jetzt
geht es wieder ins hotel mit der bahn
und irgendwie regnet ich mag die nicht
so wie köln arbeite alles was ich jetzt
sage habe ich eigentlich immer
aufgenommen aber irgendwie war es
einfach weg das hatte ich vorher nie als
hätte irgendwie das gericht im geist
oder so auf jeden fall haben wir schon
freitagmorgen in berlin ich habe mit der
sache am mittwoch angefangen so zu sagen
habe ich das eigentlich sogar ein
bisschen länger gemacht als ich
eigentlich vorhatte
natürlich waren wir auch auf der youtube
hatte oder so da gab es essen aber sonst
wenn man jetzt mal schaut wir haben hier
die rede oder hit rechnung je nach dem
netto rechnung und all die rechnungen
oder quittungen ich würde mal kurz ein
bisschen rechnen wird mir ungefähr
[Musik]
also man könnte sagen ich habe jetzt in
eineinhalb tagen dafür also in mehr als
24 stunden maximal acht euro bezahlt auf
jeden fall ganz witzig ich würde einfach
mal sagen an meiner stelle würde ich mal
an eurer stelle ich würde an seiner
stelle auf jeden fall mal kommentieren
welche challenge man eventuell noch
machen könnte ich habe jetzt gleich
einen coolen terminieren berlin und zwar
geht es um neue klamotten kommt doch
gern vorbei morgen und klagenfurt in
österreich so video kann da werde ich da
sein ich bin zwar echt ein bisschen
krank aber ich hoffe morgen geht es mir
besser
der vielleicht allen hand nein will ich
nicht also vielleicht haben ja der ein
oder andere von euch ein bisschen husten
mitbringen also leute wir sehen uns
sonntag wieder ich hoffe dass wieder
durchgefallen das noch nach oben da aber
nicht vergessen und müssen irgendwas
sagen ja